j'ai dream était avec nous merci de ta
vie et généreux alors toi aussi ton en
tournée dans toute la france
et franchement mais toi c'est un truc de
ouf c'est un truc de ouf
non mes frères c'est un truc de ouf sans
déconner grain ces clichés pour mémoire
deux et deux types de tout sur trois cds
type de toit la radio c'est un truc de
fou faire tu as payé les radios ou quoi
non non mais c'est un truc de fou depuis
juillet s'est ainsi appuyé joindrait
c'est un sas enchaîné c'est vraiment
incroyable on vit l'aventuré ensemble et
je suis vraiment content les dates à son
nom bah ouais t'as et atlas et des dates
de tournée partout hein parce qu'un
homme est franchement je kiffe tesson
[Musique]
cette farce oui
à
je sais nous regarder chez moi le 19
heures séries
déjà hollywoodien vous m'avez manqué
tout hier soir voilà je vous le dis
parce que hier soir était dans le délire
mines bim bim j'ai regardé crime après
j'ai regardé encore comme le truc
auditions alors l'amour secret là
qu'arrive secret je pense à vous à ce
point je regarde des émissions je
patiente et des spectateurs tout ça je
vous le dis j'ai pas de choses à vous
dire mais pour l'instant vg dream suis
sûr que vous êtes comme moi vous l'aimez
mais vous êtes des millions à le haïr
non mais seriez pourquoi parce que
frères mes frères à regarder un match de
foot ça n'aide pas les gens dans la rue
et le combat mais je
toute la joie il faut quoi ramener à
couper le rappel ramon la coupe non mais
ça on t'appelle ramener la coupe à la
maison j'étais comme ça a pris mais tu
sais que tu est un jalon mémoire préfère
essayer le v-twin bataille à 0,8 à
l'armée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sama
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu kiffes le foot est un gros gros
kieffer de foot comme je joue bien ou
pas non je suis très nul c'est très nul
mais tu kiffes quand même ouais parce
que il ya dans tout est donc dans la
plupart des types tu glisses un ou deux
joueurs de foot ouais c'est toujours
s'est inséré quoi qu'il arrive
servir le gars et pas de n'importe quoi
un moment il va manger un gâteau des gts
m'as tu veux mettre un joueur de foot
non c'est vous pas dans ma go / à toi tu
parles aussi dans l'oeil de tito ci est
chez moi tu veux tu es obligé de me
s'est par contre afin non seulement
avoir contraint cgc mais tu as raison
c'est que c'est sa marque de fabrique
c'est grâce à lui qu'on connaît déjà
exactement c'est vrai c'est une chose
sacrée qu'on ait gagné a coulé ou de la
chanson ont eu moins de succès sur les
perdu en quart et c'est variable sa
dernière à toi tu es un coup de chance
double chance à croire que je le fais le
jour de la finale en fait ah oui c'est
vrai annoncé aux voiliers sur jean est a
pas pris des histoires quoi tu l'as pris
sur la sortie tu t'es dit tu l'avais
déjà un peu en tête j'avais en tête mais
je me suis dit en fait c'est un cadeau
pour les joueurs c'est pas ouais
commerciale au départ ouais c'est ça
ouais vous gagnez ou c'est un cadeau
voilà et ben ouais mais c'est où l'on
chante réaliser mais tu es que tu te
rends compte que ce titre il va rester à
vie est associé marquent frères toi je
t'explique à la sacem tu prendras de
l'oseille avis
c'est sûr
non mes écrits c'est certain a été
tranquille donc si tu poèmes de des tons
costumes d'époque est déjà rentré sur
tiger pas du tout pensé à ça tu as pensé
il était actif